[Applause]
okay
a little bit of news this week uh the
president signed
bills the the other day extending
statute uh of limitations
for
investigating the fraud from the covert
money now back in april we did a piece
here a very long piece because it needed
it i thought about how much money was
stolen
covet money
because we did write checks for i think
5.7 trillion dollars when the forever
flu hit
okay so we can argue about whether that
was an appropriate amount i think it
might have been a little high
but what really pisses me off
is that so much of it was stolen and
that's what i was talking about in april
some of these numbers might have been
might be a little out of date since then
but unemployment
insurance uh for people 872 billion
went out the door they estimate
maybe up to half
was stolen
the ppp
again very unfortunate phraseology in
that party
that was the
paycheck protection program okay
this was small businesses trying to
cover their employees who were now out
of work um only a quarter paid wages
that would have otherwise been lost and
this is the question i asked back in
april and i'm going to ask it again
it doesn't really make me a conservative
does it that i don't want to be
absolutely robbed blind
is there some number at which i go you
know what
you are just taking my money
and wasting it and letting people steal
it
i mean i i get the
i get the idea that money can never be
transferred except in a leaky bucket i
accept that but this isn't a bucket
anymore it's just a handle
the issue is the bucket was designed to
be leaky that leaky half stolen
well this is what i mean government is
as functional or as dysfunctional as we
design it to be and government was
designed to be dysfunctional
um it was never this dysfunctional ppp
stands for paycheck protection program
like you said what that meant was it was
supposed to keep people continuing to
get their paychecks even as companies
had to shut down or lay off workers or
whatever the problem is the government
does not know who is getting a paycheck
from whom and who stopped getting a
paycheck the government should know
these things because companies pay taxes
they pay payroll taxes but the problem
is yes i know let's just let me finish
let me finish okay the problem is
government infrastructure sucks and
they're using software that's from the
disco era like i'm not kidding i'm not
kidding
and so what happens is the databases
can't talk to each other you know the
the software is really antiquated so we
have to rely on the honor system
essentially where companies say
uh look government i need this money i
promise you pinky swear i'm going to use
it to keep people employed and they and
some of them did but a lot of them
didn't a lot of them are not real
companies
we're not we're americans i'm sorry we
can't be on the honor system
other countries
other countries have figured out how to
invest in good government and state
capacity germany didn't do this for
example germany knows who works for whom
as our government should force germany
and they pushed out the money they
pushed out the money through firms
directly to employees they spent a lot
less per employee and they kept more
people employed if we wanted to
we could invest in good government but
we have systemically decided not to
partly because it's like not sexy to
talk about government i.t okay and
partly because that way you know the
right but i thought the governor i
thought the democrats were the were the
good government party why don't they do
it i get it the republicans want to
strangle it in the bathtub yeah but why
why isn't the other party and why aren't
the republicans you're supposed to be
we're the mean old man to watch your
money why don't they do their part
nobody does any of their part that they
should do
so i you know it makes me i agree i
agree the problem is the problem is
the government is just designed to be
dysfunctional and then republicans point
to it and say aha it's disgusting
terrible advertisement for government
let's let's cut their funding so they're
more dysfunctional this is it makes me a
little less excited about the money
they're planning to spend you can say a
lot about the the funding that we just
gushed out of this country in march of
2020 and subsequently again in 2021
february 2021. you can't say that the
consequences of rushing money out the
door with very limited oversight were
not anticipated they were anticipated we
knew that this would be a
a font of fraud and abuse and that
government would have to come back up
and clean it up prosecutors this is the
prosecutor paycheck protection act and
congress congress has to engage in
oversight here it's not enough for
inspectors general to get engaged and
say well this agency spent 75 billion on
something we don't know where it went
congress has to go back and conduct its
its proper role of overseeing its own
activities but the money's gone
you're not getting the money back and my
concern is when when there is another
crisis or recession and there will be
the choice will be between uh i guess we
shouldn't give people the help that they
need because look at all the fraud last
time like we clearly didn't know how to
get it to the right people or let's
helicopter drop more money and hope that
some of it lands in the right place
because
i mean that's basically what happened
before because
we get to be this shitty country that we
can't do anything uh i don't know okay
all right well that's the investigation
into what americans have very little
tolerance for this the investigation
into waste and abuse and during world
war ii made harry truman's career right
uh this is the sort of thing that
americans reward they don't look rightly
on people who abuse the urgent crisis we
did used to be able to do it okay
you